did you ever bring a song to the band
back in the day uh and Gene would say to
you we're not putting that on an album
but I want to tell you a story about uh
Paul walks in during 79 or so got a new
song and in the beginning by the way we
traded ideas and kind of co-wrote and
stuff and then we went off on our own so
he walks in I got a song for you what's
it called I was made for loving you oh
that's great what's the first uh line
tonight oh that's good what's the second
one I want to give it all to you oh yeah
I know what it is that's cool in the
darkness in the Darkness
okay that rocks yeah what it's something
I want to do that's really cool what's
my part
[Music]
no no come on
what's my part you were upset with the
doo doo doo doo doo you didn't like it
to this day except Stadium's full of
people they jump up and down like
biblical locusts
you do these shows we'll do festivals
and sometimes we'll find ourselves on a
bill headlining over all these very
hardcore metal bands and in the
beginning we say do we really want to
play that and you have these people on
stage you know the lead singer
and then we come on and we're going and
the whole audience is
and that that's that's the beauty of
Music it hits you here it hits you in
the heart
foreign